honey I know
I'm a daddy long
they feel
cold
you know it's like a day vacation
because I'm not at home
the other
outside the wall compared to what
I don't think of myself as outside of
the walls of any meds I think it's
strange that I'm here you know I'm not
that not that I'm discrediting a film
that maybe made a very kind of
emotionally driven film a powerful movie
that people seem to respond to and I'm
very happy about that I'm very happy
that our actor is nominated for Best
Male lead where I think is
that's to me is the greatest speak
because the Cassavetes word is great you
know I mean he's a poor father American
independent cinema and I'm honored to be
in a category even named after and let
alone in the city that he loved to
interpret but it's to have our actor
nominated with movies that cost hundreds
of times over thousand times more than
aren t not that money has much to do
with it but
can you go to that time in your life
when you knew that you
over and make money
I haven't I don't know if I made my I
definitely lived my life lived off of my
films you know for like six months at a
time so that's good I still have to
figure out a way to pay the bills and do
crappy commercial work that why I still
put my all I don't think I don't mean to
demean it I put my all and everything I
do but I just wish I didn't have to
satiate my creative bone in keeping with
our survival
I mean I liked being a busboy time I was
good but it was
humbling I actually know it was like
more cocky in a way I liked it I had an
enemy with the bread thank you very much